اثارت جنديه جزائريه اعجاب المواطنين
والرئيس عبد المجيد تبون خلال مشاركتها في
حفل تخرج دفعات الاكاديميه العسكريه في
شرشال وهي تستعرض قوتها بحمل ثلاثه رجال
على كتفيها
حامله عدو الجزائر في اكتافها تردد قائله
ورايناك في الجبال الشاهقات اريهم قوتك
واشتدي عليهم عزمك وهي قلت
[تصفيق]
بكلمات مؤثره احدث طيار لبناني مفاجاه في
عرض الزواج الذي تقدم به لفتاه كانت تنتظر
اقلاع الطائره الكابتن فتح مكبر الصوت من
داخل قمره القياده ونادى برقم مقعدها
معبرا لها عن امنيته بان تكون شريكه حياته
الفيديو
[موسيقى]
اظهر مقطع فيديو تحطم طائره صوماليه بشكل
مروع اثناء هبوطها في مطار مقديش وقد نجا
جميع ركاب اعجوبه وستقاريرا تفيد بوجودي
اصابات
[موسيقى]
تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
تصميما لمسجد في تركيا وهو من صنع رسام
اذربيجاني الفنان رسم حدائق معلقه عند
مدخل المسجد واشار بين كل نافذه ونافذه
وشلالات وراء المحراب وغيوما وسماء فالسقف
وقد استوحى الفكره من ايات في القران
الكريم بحسب وكالتي الاناضول التركيه
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات